En este lugar, informamos sobre un nuevo tipo de microalgas
que creció sobre las telarañas que cubrían la entrada de la cueva.
¿Alguna vez han visto una telaraña temprano en la mañana?
Está cubierta de rocío,
así esta microalga aprendió que para llevar fotosíntesis
en la costa del desierto más seco de la Tierra,
podrían usar las telarañas.
Entonces aquí pueden acceder al agua de las nieblas
que regularmente cubren estas áreas por la mañana.
En otra cueva, encontramos un tipo diferente de microalgas.
Este es capaz de usar niebla marina como fuente de agua,
y sorprendentemente vive en el fondo de una cueva,
por lo que se ha adaptado para vivir con menos del 0,1 %
de la cantidad de luz que necesitan las plantas comunes.
Este tipo de hallazgos sugieren que en Marte,
podemos encontrar incluso la vida fotosintética dentro de las cuevas.
Y, por cierto, ese soy yo.
(Risas)
Durante casi 15 años esta región de Yungay, descubierta por la NASA,
se pensó que era el lugar más seco de este desierto,
pero yo sabía que no era así.
¿Cómo? Uds. ya saben la respuesta.
Porque nací y crecí en este desierto.
Así que recordé que generalmente veo niebla en Yungay,
entonces, después de configurar los sensores en varios lugares,
donde recuerdo nunca haber visto nieblas o nubes,
informé de otros cuatro sitios mucho más secos que Yungay,
con esta, María Elena Sur,
siendo el lugar más seco de la Tierra,
tan seco como Marte
y, sorprendentemente, a solo 15 minutos de viaje
de la pequeña ciudad minera donde nací.
En esta búsqueda, tratábamos de encontrar realmente el límite seco
para la vida en la Tierra,
un lugar tan seco que nada pudo sobrevivir en él.
Pero incluso aquí, bien escondido bajo tierra,
encontramos una cantidad de microorganismos diversos,
lo que me sugirió que lugares similarmente secos, como Marte,
pueden estar habitados.
Incluso tenemos algunas evidencias preliminares
de que estos microorganismos aún pueden estar activos
en el estado desecado,
como momias que caminan a nuestro alrededor,
y que pueden estar usando la radiación UV como fuente de energía.
Si se confirma, esto tendría gran impacto en nuestra definición de vida,
sobre cómo buscamos la vida en otro lugar del universo.
Debido a su cielo despejado, para el 2020
el 60 % de los mayores telescopios en la Tierra
estará ubicado en Atacama,
y mientras todos los demás mirarán entre las estrellas
para responder a la pregunta: "¿Estamos solos?"
yo estaré mirando hacia el suelo
buscando esta misma respuesta
en mi propio patio trasero.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)